[Music]
I got the makings of a really great
energy
we're talking about
critics are zero
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie happy
comic-con week we just got a new Doctor
Who teaser trailer showing off the new
companions thanks to the World Cup
though they dropped this as an ad during
the finals congratulations to France I
think it's their first win in like 20
plus years but if you didn't know what's
going on here it's just them confirming
that there's gonna be three full time
companions so I'll explain who they are
but they really just want to show you
what its gonna look like even though a
lot of people are making flash jokes
there's a couple big Easter eggs for
some of the previous doctors that you
probably spotted but if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the comic-con videos it's gonna
be crazy next week and in addition to
this there will be a full trailer that
they'll drop at their Doctor Who panel
on Sunday next week so if you are
waiting for more actual footage don't
worry they'll be dropping plenty of that
role soon and I'm sure they'll be
explaining in full detail who these new
companions are because we really only
have single names for them they haven't
given character descriptions yet they've
just shown you who they are
so this first person is tossin Cole he's
named Ryan the second person is Yasmin
she's played by Amanda Gill and then
this last person is Bradley Walsh he's
playing someone called Graham he seems
like a slightly more serious version of
Wilfred Mott who is Donna nobles
grandfather if you haven't been keeping
up on Doctor Who and you're wondering
like where this series exists and what
they're gonna be doing with the time
lords and Gallifrey I think because this
is such a big change in terms of the
visual style and the makeup of the show
in the showrunner itself and the way
it's written like Chris Chibnall first
episode Steven Moffat is long gone
they're gonna wait into the series the
same way they waded into David Tennant
so like you start off in either the
doctor is kind of broken or the TARDIS
itself is kind of broken trapping them
on planet Earth for the first adventure
speaking of which that might be why they
included some of the Matt Smith Easter
eggs although I think that was just to
pay reference to some of the previous
doctors the really obvious one you
probably noticed was the Beano comic
that's from Matt Smith's run from rings
of octan he just hid behind one
[Music]
if you're not from the UK or Great
Britain that's just a children's comic
book magazine it'd be like the doctor
reading a Marvel comic book part of the
charm of Matt Smith's doctor was is that
he was very anachronistic like you have
this old tiny man in a young man's body
so that was part of the humor of him
reading a children's comic book so maybe
they are going a little Wilfred Mott
with this older Graham character but
he's tall and thin wears a brown suit
maybe a blue suit with a long brown coat
modern sort of hair all sticky-uppy all
right oh and I'm Paige to be on the
lookout for a police box
exactly but obviously Yasmin and Brian
are the more traditional young
companions I don't know if all three
will be travelling on the TARDIS
offworld all the time but like I said I
think the first episode will be like
Matt Smith's first episode or David
Tennant first episode where it's largely
an adventure that takes place on earth
then they start going into outer space
this isn't real is it this is some kind
of big wind-up what would I warn you off
so you believe me then I grew up the
only other big Easter eggs that I
spotted in this were the fish Dixon
custard which is also a Matt Smith thing
from his first episode I need I need
fish fingers and custard
[Music]
big shout out for Amy Pond currently
fighting fan OHS in a galaxy far far
away pizza was a bit of a plot device
during parting of ways in love and
monsters so you could call that a 9th or
10th doctor Easter Egg to the other
really noticeable change besides just
the visual style and the way they do the
special effects is the logo itself we
haven't seen the full title sequence yet
but I'm assuming that'll be part of the
comic-con trailer next week - there's
still like a lot of stuff that they
haven't reintroduced yet because even
though they're doing their best to keep
the continuity intact it's a huge
creative reboot for the series Orange
Lee thanks to the showrunner change so
early prediction first episode does
gangbusters ratings and then it sort of
settles into the regular weekly audience
anytime there's a new doctor you get all
kinds of people that would never watch
Doctor Who checking it out just to see
what it looks like then you have the
core audience so we'll see how many
people that lapse during Steven Moffat
Sarah will come back to the series let
me know in the comments though are you
excited for Chris Chibnall to take over
and for this new creative direction
whatever the rest of the series is gonna
look like like this is only a taste it
was a bit of a scandal a little while
ago because some footage leaked there
wasn't finished CG usually I can't
touched up like that because the BBC
goes into hardcore super band mode it'll
be interesting to see how they invoke
new who continuity and Easter eggs from
classic who I think when it comes to
continuity it's a lot easier to
cherry-pick moments from classic who
like they started to do towards the end
of Capaldi's run there was literally a
lot of classic who there at the end
I am I wearing please never take those
off
what's browser history but you always
hear writers complain when they get too
bogged down in continuity so it'll be
interesting to see how they handle all
that going forward and how many series
Jody Whitaker's doctor sticks around for
right now the benchmark is like three
four series so we'll see how long she
endures this is a clip from the only
real big official interview that she's
done so far talking about the character
and what her run is going to be like
because in this world particularly
the there aren't rules and it's that's a
great thing you know so hopefully
hopefully everyone's excited as excited
as I am
it was brilliant out there because the
distraction of how full-on this job was
and the schedule for that was was epic
so it was brilliant because it was a
complete you know I could not split my
attention in any way so I wasn't at home
tempted to kind of text anyone or tell
anyone because I was on set all day she
won't take over from Peter Capaldi on
Doctor Who until the very end of his
final story at Christmas so far she's
loved the support from fans it's been
you know hugely positive and that is a
wonderful way to start this massive
journey that will be you know for the
rest of your life as well it's one of
the only roles you can really say you
are that character forever let me know
in the comments what do you guys think
about the new look of the series the new
doctor and what you want them to bring
back like I said comic-con is starting
next week it really doesn't start till
Thursday so there'll be a couple days
before it gets started I'll do a
schedule video that'll explain all the
stuff that I'm going to be doing but
leave your requests in the comments
below I'll pin a special Comic Con
playlist is the top of my channel so you
guys will be able to find all those
videos pretty easily while you wait for
everything click here to watch Tom
Holland reveal some of the plot of
Avengers 4 and click here for brand-new
Game of Thrones thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight